[موسيقى]
حانت ساعه الرحيل
الى اي مكان يحفظ حياه طفليها تركت عملها
وهجرت منزلها وكل شيء
لا استطيع الكلام انني حزينه جدا
انسحبت القوات الروسيه من المدينه وعاد
الاوكرانيون لكن صوت الموت مازال يهدر في
المقاطعه الجنوبيه
لذلك نشدت السلطات السكان النزوحه الى
مقاطعه وسطي اوكرانيا وغربها الاقل تضررا
هنا يتحللون من اعباء الحرب يضعون اثقالهم
وهمومهم فينظرون
وعائلتها النزوح بعد اشهر من الانتظار
لدينا منزل لقد قصبه الروس لم يعد لدينا
اي شيء هذه واحده من عشرات النقاط التي
وفرت السلطات الاوكرانيه لاجلاء السكان من
غير سؤال بشكل طبيعي في ظل الاستمرار
القصف الروسي على المدينه وانعدام الخدمه
في ساحات المدينه تنتشر خيام وفرتها
السلطات لاستقبال طلبات الراغبين في
النزوح اكثر من 300,000 كانوا يعيشون في
مقاطعه غير سون قبل الحرب لم يبقى منهم
الكثير
حاليا هي كبار السن والنساء والاطفال
ومحطات انتظار مؤقته لتوزيع الناس اتباعا
على المقاطعات الاكثر امنا
من استطاع الوصول الى هنا يعد او فرح الظن
فثم تغده الاستثنائيه في زمن الحرب لا
يجدها كثيرون حرب يؤمن الا تطول كثيرا
تامر صمادي الجزيره غير صوت